good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the supervisor of the former police
officer accused of murdering george
floyd has told the court
the restraint of mr floyd should have
stopped when he'd been handcuffed and
was no longer offering any resistance
the trial has also been hearing from mr
floyd's girlfriend who described how
they'd met
at a salvation army shelter derek chovin
has pleaded not guilty to murder
and manslaughter charges our u.s
correspondent greg milam reports
i do courtney ross had been in a
relationship with george floyd for
nearly three years by the time he died
may i tell the story sure okay
uh it's one of my favorite stories
they'd met when he worked as a security
guard at the salvation army shelter
he said um
can i pray with you it was so sweet
at the time both though developed
addictions to opioids
during their relationship the lawyer for
derek chovin
asked her about taking george floyd to
hospital two months before his death
you spent several days with him at the
hospital correct yes
and did you learn what that what caused
that overdose
no at that time frame did you learn that
mr floyd was taking anything other than
opioids
no
you did not know that he had taken
heroin at that time
no two weeks before his death she said
she became aware he was using opioids
again
i noticed a change in his behavior the
defense claimed george floyd died of a
drugs overdose
not as the result of the force of a
police officer's knee on his neck
for nine minutes the jury heard from
paramedics
who said they felt george floyd was
already dead when they arrived
and they heard derek chauvin talking to
his supervisor
straight after had to hold the guy down
he was uh
was uh going crazy wasn't going
coming off at the moment he never
mentioned kneeling on george floyd's
neck
his former colleague was asked if that
would be considered
excessive force and is the placement of
a
knee on a subject's neck uh
a use of force yes a reportable type of
force
not necessarily and why is that
uh for handcuffing somebody in a prone
position or
fighting with someone it could happen
where your knee ends up on their neck
for about how long
i guess whatever's reasonable okay which
would be when
uh until you get control of the party i
guess
control is in the person is that
handcuffed
handcuffed and not continuing to fight
with you anymore
so once the person once the subject is
handcuffed and no longer
resisting yes at that point
the restraint should stop
yeah it's been an exhaustive
at times graphic examination of the
events of that day
difficult for everyone involved and a
country watching intently
greg milam sky news minneapolis
and sky news will have continuous
coverage of proceedings in the trial of
derek shovin streaming live on our
website and
app on youtube and on a special pop-up
channel which is pin protected
on sky channel 524
at least 34 people have died after a
train derailed inside a tunnel in taiwan
more than 70 others have been injured
with rescue services struggling to reach
parts of the train
malaysia correspondent tom cheshire
joins me now tom
what's the situation at the moment and
what more do we know about exactly what
happened
we know this train derailed around 9am
on the east
of taiwan it is coming up to tomb
sweeping day which is a big holiday when
lots of people travel
and 350 people were on this train as it
made its way through a very mountainous
region
of taiwan it derailed and you can see
some people of course have made it out
pretty much
unharmed but at least 30 dead and many
more still trapped
inside what appears to have happened is
the train hit
some sort of vehicle uh potentially a
cargo truck or a service vehicle
which obviously shouldn't have been
there on the rails and that
uh caused the carriages to uh scrape
against the walls crumpled them it's
ripped them
apart and that's also making the rescue
effort very difficult it's inside this
tunnel
um so they are trying to get those
people out
those confirmed deaths already make it
the worst train crash
in taiwan for decades in 2018 there was
a crash where 18 people died in 91
another crash where 30 people died so
this has already surpassed those
horrible totals um and they will be
trying to get those people
out for the rest of it now this is a
high-speed train it's a very very safe
network
things like this aren't supposed to
happen and obviously that vehicle was
not supposed to be
in the way but rescue services as you
can see they're trying their best to
reach those carriages in the middle
of the tunnel those crumpled carriages
and see if they can reach the people
still trapped inside and see
whether they can still be saved tom
thank you for that update
more than 70 mps including 40
conservatives say plans to use
coronavirus vaccine passports in the uk
will be divisive and discriminatory
boris johnson says there will definitely
be a role
for the passports for britons to head
abroad and there are suggestions they
could be trialled at some
pilot events according to the institute
for government
the passports are most likely to be
available via a mobile app or the
existing
general nhs app verification could be
sought from
facial recognition or integration with
nhs medical records
the government review is considering
whether a vaccine passport
could allow visitors entry to venues
such as pubs theatres and
sports stadiums interim results are due
on monday
israel has so far moved furthest with
vaccine passports
green passes are valid a week after a
second vaccine dose
and allow people to use leisure
facilities like hotels and gyms
let's get more from our political
correspondent rob powell um they've been
discussed
quite quite a bit uh vaccine passport
but with
more than 70 mps warning against them
how likely are they to be brought in
well i think it depends um jillian on a
number of factors i guess one is whether
they want to make it
give it a legal underpinning if you like
write it into law requirements to have
vaccine passports
if that was the case you'd need to have
legislation going through the house of
commons and then the government could
run into
trouble especially if labor are opposed
to it
um i think the other issue really for
boris johnson to consider
is what circumstances he plans to use
these sorts of certificates for
i think for international travel there's
little controversy about that an
acceptance that other countries will
ask for certain proofs before you're
allowed into the country
it starts to get more sticky when you're
talking about
getting into everyday services like
shops like pubs as boris johnson had
suggested
in relation to pubs that is what these
70 mps 40 of them conservatives
but plenty of labour mps people like
jeremy corbyn that have signed this
pledge as well
they say that they don't want the use of
covid certificates
to essentially block people off from
getting into everyday business being
part of their community
or getting jobs as well i think the
other
big factor that the government will have
to consider is what's the alternative
how else can you prove that you're safe
if you haven't had the vaccine because
you can't have it or because you don't
want to have it and that was something
that boris johnson touched on
on a visit to t-side yesterday i think
when it comes to
trying to make sure that we give maximum
confidence to business and to
to customers and uh here in the in the
uk there are
uh there are three things as your
immunity
uh whether you've had it before so
you've got natural antibodies anyway
whether you've been
vaccinated then of course whether you've
had a test
and so those three things working
together will i think uh be useful
for us as we as we go forward now we
know there's going to be a number of
pilot events running in the next month
or so
some fa cup uh matches also the world
snooker championship at the crucible
theatre
in sheffield where people attending will
be tested before and after
and interactions if you like the results
of that will be studied by experts
to see how to safely reopen sporting
events
the daily mail in the daily telegraph
reporting this morning that vaccine
passports vaccine
certification could also play a role in
those pilots
uh now overnight the government not
confirming anything and saying this is
all subject to an ongoing review
we should get the first interim results
of that on monday
okay rob thank you other stories making
the news this morning and police have
issued warnings against people gathering
over the easter weekend
with several kill the bill protests
being organized the metropolitan police
says it will take enforcement action if
needed in the interests of public
health a number of protests against the
proposed police
crime sentencing and courts bill have
ended in violence
police in belgium have used water cannon
to try to disperse a crowd of thousands
of young people who'd gathered in one of
the biggest parks in brussels
despite coronavirus restrictions a party
had been advertised on social media
and around 2 000 people turned up
another event has been advertised for
tonight oxfam has confirmed it has
suspended
two members of staff in the democratic
republic of congo
over allegations of sexual misconduct
and bullying
the charity previously faced complaints
in 2018
after further allegations of sexual
exploitation by aid workers
in response to the 2010 haiti earthquake
oxfam said they're working hard to
conclude the investigation
fairly safely and effectively
there's fresh doubt being cast on the
safety of smart motorways
an independent report has found that
drivers are 200 percent more likely to
break down on a live motorway lane
if they're on a smart motorway which has
no hard shoulder
and it says that when they do break down
they're more likely to die
the report was commissioned by lawyers
representing the widow of a man who died
on a smart section of the m1
melena vasilinovich reports claire
mercer's husband jason was a colorful
and loving person she says
nearly two years ago he and another
driver were killed in the section of the
m1 motorway without a hard shoulder
they had a miner shunt and pulled into
the left lane but minutes later
a lorry plowed into them when i opened
my door to police officers
i just i just froze and i just i started
with the worst case scenario thinking
anything they say could only be an
improvement and i just said is he alive
and after pushing they wanted me to go
in but i just couldn't move
i said it again and they said no and i
fell to the floor
they had to pick me up the lorry driver
was jailed for 10 months
but claire mercer believes her husband
would still be alive if there was a hard
shoulder
and a coroner in the inquest into his
death said it was clear
that its absence contributed to the
tragedy
some motorways like this one behind me
don't have a hard shoulder where motors
can pull up if they have an accident
instead the entire carriageway is open
to traffic in order to reduce congestion
and the lane is only shut once there's
an accident
an independent report commissioned by
claire mercer's lawyers
says this makes the roads more risky it
found that motorways where all lanes are
running are associated with the highest
rate of people killed
or seriously injured fundamentally in
all lane running motorways we have a
motorway which is less safe now than the
original smart motorways
and as a result people are dying or
being seriously injured
on those roads in terms of the
decision-making that has led to this
point
the evidence suggests that those
decisions have been underpinned by
evidence which is
incomplete and which hasn't really made
those decisions fully informed
highways england said that they are
reviewing the report in a statement they
wrote
the government's evidence stock take of
the safety of smart motorways analyzed a
wealth of data
and found that in most ways they are as
safe as or safer
than conventional motorways we are
committed to delivering the stock take
actions to further raise the bar on
smart motorway safety
for claire mercer there's no relief from
the pain of losing her husband
i still expect him to to walk through
the door
um the only thing that tells me that it
is real is he still keeps not coming
home
so you just you just don't get used to
it
her wish now is to make the road safer
for others
milena vassalinovic sky news
for joining me now is the president of
the aaa edmund king good morning to you
and before we talk about the safety and
what exactly are smart motorways and
what are the different types
yes smart motorways were first
introduced around
2006 and the first was on the m42 in the
west midlands
and what that was it used the hard
shoulder
as a live running lane when it was
congested
and that worked quite well because there
were emergency lay-bys every 500 meters
there were
overhead gantries so if there was a
problem most people could get to an
emergency
labor then what happened after
2006 that were rolled out to other
motorways the m25 the m1 etc
but then the criteria changed so rather
than having emergency refuges at
500 meters the regulation changed to
2500 meters or a mile and a half
and that's when problems started because
people breaking down
could not get to that emergency refuge
area
now some of them are all lane running
and what that means is that the hard
shoulder
is a live lane all of the time 24
hours a day others are what they call a
dynamic hard shoulder
and the hard shoulder is only used as a
live running lane when it's busy
and this is also led to confusion but
you know the main sticking point really
has been the 38
people who break down on a live
motorway on a smart bedway in a live
lane
and we put that down to the lack of
these emergency refuge areas which means
in many cases people frankly have got
nowhere to go
essentially the question is smart
motorways in their their current form
do you believe that they're safe
in their current form we don't believe
they're safe because the whole thing
about
smart motorways is that they were meant
to have technology
to make them safe so they were meant to
have a stop
vehicle detection system that if a
vehicle did break down
in a live lane it would be spotted
but that was not rolled out at the same
time there was only
23 miles on the m25 that had that radar
system
and a small section section now on the
m3 they are
looking at rolling that out but there
still are
questions so this report that's just
come
come out actually adds more questions
and it actually talks about a safe
system
in in any engineering you actually have
to engineer
in for human error you know if things go
wrong how does the system work and this
report suggests that that was
not done at all in the early years
and i think that that is a grave concern
sorry sorry to interrupt we're running
out of time but it's going to be very
worrying for people listening hearing
you president of the aaa saying that
they're not safe and as we speak there
are people driving on these smart
motorways
well indeed and we've we've been talking
about this for 10 years
and we've put proposals to the
government to make them much
safer and this report and four coroners
say that so
you know for drivers make sure your
car's in good
good condition try and prevent breaking
down on a smart motorway and if you can
don't stop drive the extra mile to the
era
drive to the exit and if you do break
down in a live lane and cannot get
out on the inside lane the advice is put
your hazard lights on keep your
seat belts on and dial 999.
if it is that serious
edmond king president of the a thank you
very much for uh speaking to us and
uh handing out that advice thank you
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with the joe what have you got
a surprise i think for most people
unless well i mean of course this last
week we saw temperatures up to 24 25
degrees celsius
it looked like summer it felt like
summer the thing is it wasn't summer
uh we have got quite a quiet weekend but
then the cold air returns monday tuesday
bitterly cold
showers of hail sleet and snow strong
northerly winds as well and that cold
air is with us for
a few days yet let's take a look at the
weekend though
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
it's actually quite a quiet start for
this good friday
uh plenty of sunshine out towards the
west although it's cold temperatures
have dipped below freezing in some parts
of the northwest
a little bit more cloudy out towards the
east and that's very much going to be
the way things are
over the next couple of days so lovely
sunshine through
much of scotland ireland parts of wales
in the southwest this cloud through
central southern southeastern areas
will thin and break to allow some sunny
spells but it's breezier here as well
and those temperatures will be not back
into single figures whereas out towards
the west we could see 13 or 14 degrees
celsius
that's 57 degrees fahrenheit and then as
we go through this evening overnight
that cloud starts to come back but
expect a frost in the northwest
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well let's return to the news that the
government could soon trial
vaccine passports at some pilot events
for joining me now is
silky carlo the director of big brother
watch good morning to you
um initially what what are your thoughts
on the proposals of
uh vaccination passports and their use
i think this is a really really
troubling idea it's
unnecessary we've got a fantastic
vaccination program we should be coming
out of
this crisis it's unworkable and it's
unbritish
you know we're not a nation that lives
unlicensed we're not a nation that
carries
id cards and frankly the idea of
carrying covered passes which is like an
id card on steroids you know immediately
would hold very sensitive health data
to try to implement a segregation policy
i mean we haven't seen anything like
this in britain for decades
is very very troubling this should be a
moment for optimism and instead i think
we find ourselves on the precipice
of a serious civil liberties war
the idea isn't to implement a
segregation policy though is it
it's to allow people to be able to
operate and go about their
their daily business and access services
and to protect
each other well the point of it is to
prevent
some people from accessing services and
that means some people are going to be
denied
tickets that they've paid for or jobs
that they have
this is all about segregation it's all
about exclusion
and the government is going about this
in exactly the wrong way
if as everyone wants to you know there's
a common goal here everyone wants to
come out of lockdown and for everyone to
be healthy
safe and free you don't do that by
excluding people you don't do that by
creating a digital surveillance
infrastructure
that's designed to exclude the most
marginalized people
and also including people who are unable
to have a vaccine or don't have access
um to to health care as easily as others
we're talking about minority of people
but for example
how what would the situation be for
pregnant women who routinely
aren't offered vaccination at the moment
i mean how long are people going to be
expected to show their papers
one of my fears is that once such an
extreme policy in such an extreme system
like this is introduced
we will never see the back of it and it
would only expand and expand into other
health issues
other use cases that would turn us into
a very very different society indeed
what would you propose instead by means
of
allowing people to to lead full lives
and access services as i said before
well what we really need is
for everyone to be safe at a community
level
and that's the only sensible way in
which things can start to reopen which
frankly i think should be happening
right now it should be happening very
soon
um because the vaccination program is
going very well
and we're seeing very very high uptake
as well so the most vulnerable people
are broadly now protected so we need to
see on ongoing measures protections at
work etcetera to make sure that
people are safe and then really good
contact tracing
so that you can you don't need to treat
the whole population as though they're
infectious you can actually track
infections and let's remember dido
harding head of testing trace
has 37 billion pounds to spend on test
and trace and as par
parliamentary committees have said we're
not really seeing the returns on that
where the money is being spent is where
we should be seeing
um people now being kept safer
and us being in a situation where we can
reopen not that we need to turn into
some kind of discriminatory dystopia
where
anyone from bosses to bouncers can
demand your papers
create two cues at football games or at
pubs
and tell people that they're not allowed
in that is not in any in a democratic
society that's not a sensible way
forward
okay silky carlo director of big brother
watch thank you for sharing your views
with us definitely against
the introduction of vaccination
passports there
still to come we have all of the sport
with jackie what have you got coming up
for a lot of food
i'm going to be talking about food i
can't stop thinking about food actually
because it's easter
and we're going to tell you what's on
dustin johnson's menu for the masters
dinner it's delicious
also is former premier league boss eddie
howe on verge of return to football
management eight months
after leaving bournemouth and could
super league champion helen start their
title defense with two wins from
two at whole kr
[Music]
do social media platforms do enough to
curb media abuse of footballers and
sports stars
arsenal think not let's have a look
i think it is sort of like an american
apple crumble anyway this is sky news
breakfast coming up
ready to roll we speak to the 89 year
old hoping to raise money for a charity
by skating round a courtyard there he is
[Music]
now inspiration is passing around the
country exemplified by
energetic pensioners determined to raise
money for good causes by showing the
rest of us how to get active
89 year old dr john wilcox set out to
raise 500 pounds for food poverty
charity
fair share on his just giving page but
he's already gained more than 28 000
pounds and i'm pleased to say dr john
joins me now from warwick good morning
to you um so tell us exactly what the
challenge is that that you've taken
up yes what i'm trying to do is roll
escape round
the courtyard here for 90 laps
that represents 90 or one lap for every
year of my life i'll be 90 in january
so 90 laps for 90 years sir tom
moore did 100 laps for 100 years
he did it with his trolley i'm going to
do it with my trolley but
with the addition of uh roller skates
well happy birthday to you when it does
arrive but why
roller skates well it would be easy to
walk
and in any case i quite like roller
skating what i did in my younger days
uh i haven't skated for 70 years and i'm
a bit rusty but
it's all coming back now i roller skated
when i was younger as well
i wouldn't attempt to get into a pair of
roller skates now it's not that easy
to um actually manage roller skating
oh dear i think we've lost
dr john wilcock there
oh and he was just going to tell me
about uh his roller skating
um prowess and oh have we got him back
have we got him back are you back with
us dr john
oh lovely oh yes i was just saying that
you know i didn't find roller skating
particularly easy myself
how have you managed to to master it
it's been so many years since you put on
a pair of roller skates
well that's right it started when i was
in the raf
stationed in chroma in north norfolk and
i was 19 and it was a good way to meet
young ladies
uh plenty of them around and to get
really close
you had to learn to dance and i was
quite good
at roller skating and dancing at the
same time
so that's how it all began and i think
once you've learned to ride a bike
it's uh it's time to come back again so
so a good way to to meet young ladies
you say
are you planning on doing that now well
um
i'm a bit short of time really i don't
have much time left
i better get on with it if uh if i'm
going to
are you a little bit worried though
because it's it's a little bit dangerous
isn't it
well that's right what skating yes
i i wear i mean i don't really can see
this i've got overall pads on
and i've got knee pads on i've got my
cars helmets on
so it's all taken care of
oh i'm not expecting to do any crash
diving
but you got the helmet on just in case
you can never be too careful
you can never be too careful now tell us
a little bit about your training because
you've been training on something called
a rollator
with a with a walking aid that's been
put together especially for
you no no that's that's a standard uh
a walking aid that's the thing that sir
tom used to get around his courtyard
a plenty of them around oh i it belongs
to my wife
that's it there in front of me in that
picture
uh and that's it there i just read
without it i can't escape i just fall
fast on my back
yeah you got to you've got to keep a
firm grip of of that haven't you and so
tell us
tell us about the charity that that
you're raising the money for
yes i came across that through
to the work of marcus rushford the
footballer
when he set about his campaign to
to make free school meals available for
children during the holidays
uh when i was a kid we were a bit
strapped for cash and i
i know what it's like to go to school
hungry and i
enjoyed preschool dinners so and i i
looked him up on the internet and i
found that he was associated with a
charity called fair share
which is a childhood that rescues food
from supermarkets at the end of the day
when it would normally be thrown out
because it would
it's out of date it would then go into
into landfill causing problems for the
environment
they rescue it and redistribute it to
needy families so it's sort of a double
bonus really
well a very good cause indeed and dr
john wilcock
you wanted to raise just 500 pounds
you're already at 28 000 pounds
so we wish you continued success with
your fundraising
all up until your 90th birthday and
happy birthday in advance
lovely thank you very much thank you a
lot
brilliant makes me ashamed we should all
be doing our bit no matter the age
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with joe
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well for
much of the weekend it'll be fine for
roller skating but by the time we get to
monday
maybe you want to be looking at ice
skates or potentially skis instead
because it's going to turn very wintry
and this is going to be quite a surprise
given the fact we had temperatures up to
24 degrees celsius
last week so we still got high pressure
with us at the moment so it's very calm
it's very settled it's dry in most
places
uh rather more in the way of cloud
across central southern southeastern
areas
that cloud will thin a little and break
so we'll see some sunny spells coming
through
but always the best of the sunshine up
towards the northwest and here we'll see
temperatures up to around 13 or 14
degrees celsius that's 57 degrees
fahrenheit
cooler on those north sea coast with an
onshore breeze and temperatures
really struggling to get higher than
around seven or eight celsius
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
at 7 43 you're watching sky news
breakfast coming up we'll take a look at
the newspapers with the entrepreneur
kate hardcastle
and the former editor of the daily star
dawn leeson do stay with us
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school
can help stop toxic air getting trapped
in our classrooms
[Music]
the weather stays very quiet through
today with northwestern parts saying the
best of the sunshine after a chilly
start
temperatures reaching around 13 or 14
degrees celsius in those sunny western
areas
that's 57 degrees fahrenheit central
southern southeastern areas
always a little more cloudy but some
sunny spells will come through
at times and for most it's going to be
low levels of air pollution but we could
just see isolated patches of moderate
air pollution
along those eastern coasts
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
with us now to take us through the
newspapers entrepreneur kate hardcastle
and the former editor of the daily star
dawn neeson welcome back to you both and
we're starting with yorkshire post kate
and you've had a look at this story um
which is talking about the north-south
divide and government
contracts yes it's um
particularly focused in the fact that
labour mp gareth thomas believes that
there's a
procurement bias that procurements that
have been over a certain amount
of of um contracts have been awarded
uh more more to the south east in london
than
anywhere else across the uk and
obviously that leads to
issues in terms of the opportunity for
organizations out of london
and southeast um being able to be
awarded those contracts now the
government have
come back and said that they have
absolutely committed to a program of
reform
and i think we've got to see more
balance i
started off life up here in yorkshire um
as a student where i was told there was
no way with this accident i could
achieve
the things i wanted to achieve in my
working life i then worked
internationally a lot and what i saw was
that you would always have
some extra wealth around the capitals in
different countries
but studies have shown that this divide
this um imbalance is
is pretty unique to the uk in terms of
countries
who are in the most advanced of
economies
it doesn't lend well does it for a kind
of tiny postage stamp of an island that
we live on and now i've come back to the
north
and seeing some of the brilliance that
is here in industry technology and
beyond
i think we are only our best selves if
we do get balance we're only our best
selves if we
have much more of a collaborative nature
and that we
perhaps can get some of the power shift
and some of the awareness of just what a
rich and brilliant country we are
in terms of all parts not just the
element that sits around the epicenter
in london
kate um we have heard this argument a
lot though haven't we about the the
north south divided i mean it seems to
have been going on
since time in memoriam um we've had the
um
what was it george osborne's uh the
northern powerhouse
but it's still happening
and there's a lot of people in the north
that aren't quite sure that northern
powerhouse is everything we need it to
be i think as soon as we stamp something
north or south is it really the approach
we want to take
surely it's got to be about making sure
the right people are in the room we get
diversity of every single part of our
lives include
geographic region it's so important that
we get rid of the snobbery that there
might be in terms of
where we sit in the uk where we come
from uh as i said we're a tiny island
and there's nearly 65 million of us
on it we need to make sure that we we're
balanced in in our approach
internationally yeah dawn you're shaking
your head there
nodding nodding in agreement no yeah
absolutely i can i couldn't agree with
kate moore i mean my husband's family
are from manchester and i do find it
astonishing that
you know politicians in particular see
obsessed with london and the southeast
anything that happens outside of this
area
isn't that important oh it's just the
north or of the southwest
also suffers in a similar vein doesn't
it oh it's just you know it's dev and
cornwall no one really cares just go
there on holiday
it's ludicrous i mean that we are we are
as kate quite rightly said in 2021
still this divided it's mad don't take
us into the the telegraph and this story
about the eu factory
at the heart of the vaccine route
yeah talking of device julian this one
is even more interesting this
is the ongoing saga of the eu and the
vaccination program or lack of it
especially in france
at the moment um this is um it's a great
telegraph exclusive actually
british taxpayers have funded the eu
factory at the heart of the vaccine
round this is a factory
that is actually in in holland
in leiden in holland and it was british
taxpayers that literally
um having cut the factory to produce
doses of the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine meanwhile the eu haven't
invested a penny
despite the scientists involved in this
saying look this is going to work we
need this factory up and running
um you know you need to invest in it as
well but they haven't it's in holland
even the dutch haven't invested in it
um and taxpayers british taxpayers um
wreath of 21 million pounds it's
supposedly been invested in it
and elite letter has revealed all of
this um
the factory should have been invested in
last april by the year
and the european union is saying now
despite that we have paid for it
that they are not going to there any
vaccines produced at this factory
come to the uk until europe have been
looked after it's it's just
it's a whole mess again julian and you
know we know france now we're going into
another three-week lockdown and
macron is having all sorts of problems
in france with you know the vaccine safe
no it's not safe or you can do it you
can't do it
and you know and germany and holland are
the same and it's like you know
the fact that people's lives are on the
line here you know
let's come to the chase here this is not
about politics
this is about people's lives and this
factory is producing
loads of vaccines that are going to be
sort of like gridlocked
because of politics it's just utter
madness
okay let's look at something completely
different this is really interesting
story about
uh apple founder steve jobs and his uh
one of his early application forms for a
job
there were two things i wanted to buy
this week julian and i couldn't find the
extra hundreds of thousands of pounds
down the sofa the first was the motel
in the i'm actually i'm allowed to say
the program's name the program that won
all the emmys
that is something creek they're selling
the motel that was featured in that uh
big series and the other thing is this
laptop it's a huge sliding doors moment
if you're a business geek like me
this is a handwritten application for a
job um
by steve jobs who is looking for a job
in technology
um and it was written in 1973 when he
was just 18 years old it's been sold at
auction for 204 000 pounds
and um i think it's the
idea that if this job would have gone
ahead no one's quite sure whether he
just
didn't get the job or he decided not to
take the job
did he get the job right if he didn't
get the job
he then went on to work at atari with
steven wozniak and the two of them
together
founded this partnership this
inspiration aspirational relationship
that went on to then
create apple and co so i think it's just
a fantastic piece of history
yeah very expensive they are 204 000
pounds
for a piece of paper the teenager's
application on
um to the star and dawn tell us about
emojis what does it tell us about
ourselves when we send them
okay that's a good example if you ever
do this
as an emoji yeah you're in serious
trouble because it means you're an
old foggy um this is a i know
sorry um this is a survey survey of 16
to 29 year olds
who are dissing people's messaging
skills that's our messaging skills
basically julia
um with emojis that are cool and emojis
that aren't called
um basically you if you send the
the thumbs up the heart or or that
um or the tick or one of my favorites
which is the hand over the eyes one i
don't
i tend to use that one a lot that means
you're you're you're
old you're past really shouldn't use
emojis
um however um the ones that are good the
aubergine one you might not be shocked
to hear
the peach drooling face and the hearts
for eyes
the one that no one likes no matter what
age group is the skull and crossbones
right i've never sent that one i've
never had the calls to
send that one um i'll stop sending the
thumbs ups now
to the uh times cages very quickly
animals that have their own culture
yes so you know i'm quite happy to admit
i'm a huge part of the animal rights as
we all are and this is a chimpanzee in a
study that a few years ago
decided julie would stick a piece of
grass in her ear no one knows quite why
but then in her group other chimpanzees
started to stick a piece of grass in the
ear too
and she would pick up obviously grass
would fall off so she'd pick another
piece
stick it on her ear i think the more or
less chimpanzees
can be beautiful as well
dawn and kate thank you so much seeing
the next star